okay today I'm going to talk about the
water cycle in the water cycle water is
constantly being recycled and that's
what I'm going to show you today how
that works so just so you understand the
diagram that I've done in done right
here I've got a mountain here here we
have a river running through I have a
forest here the sea is here and we've
got a nice bright sunshine here so let's
see how water moves around from one
place to another
now let's I'm gonna start by talking
about the water in the sea and this
could also be water on the land the
thermal energy from the Sun causes a lot
of that water to evaporate so we have
evaporation so that's a lot of this
water turns from liquid to a gas because
of the thermal energy from the Sun now
that causes water to turn into a gas
called water vapour now that's not the
only way that we get creation of water
vapor water also evaporates from trees
and other plants water loss from a
plant's the scientific term for that is
transpiration so water is lost from here
from trees and it forms water vapor now
all of this water vapor starts to rise
up and as it does it starts to pool
because it's yeah because it's warmed by
the thermal energy causes it to rise but
as it does it starts to condense we have
condensation and as it condenses it
forms clouds so because it's got cooler
as its cooled cooled down that's what
the vapors cooled down it started to go
back from a gas into a liquid and that
is called condensation so what's going
to happen next our water well we're
gonna have it falling down as rain it
could be snow it could be sleep now that
term is called precipitation the reason
why we just don't just say rain is
because it can be snow it could be sleet
it could be rain so precipitation is
just water for
from the sky like that okay so next up
now it's not all going to go in rivers
some of it might just drain through the
soil but it's then going to drain back
into the sea so it drains into the sea
and the cycle continues it goes round
and round and round so just the recap
water is evaporated from the sea and the
land by the thermal energy provided by
the Sun this forms water vapour also we
have water evaporating from trees or
water lost from plants and trees
that's called transpiration contribute
to this water vapor this warm water
vapor rises and as it does we have
condensation which is turning from a gas
to a liquid as we have condensation in
the formation of clouds we have
precipitation which is the scientific
term for rain sleet snow basically water
falling from the sky then what we have
is the rest of this water or this water
eventually will end up draining into the
sea and the cycle continues and that's
the water cycle thank you